bonsoir nous sommes le 12 décembre
nouvelle édition du 7 8 en direct à 18h
si vous venez de nous rejoindre et ce
soir une page spéciale omar sy l'enfant
de trappes est revenu dans les yvelines
à montigny le bretonneux plus
précisément pour présenter en
avant-première son nouveau film avec
laurent lafitte de l'autre côté du
périph
nous y étions c'était hier soir à l'ugc
et ce sera à découvrir tout à l'heure
nous sommes le mercredi et le mercredi
c'est le jour de la chronique culture
avec jean massoud ribbons soir jeunes
est un symbole frites bonsoir à tout
cela pour cette chronique culture du 12
12 12 et bien nous parlerons musique
noël forcément parce que c'est bientôt
noël et puis star academy un petit poème
de madère chronique de fait un petit peu
oui à votre anniversaire aujourd'hui
bonne anniversaire déjà forcément ce
sera un petit air de fête pour tout à
l'heure vous retrouve donc dans à peu
près la lumière jaune on passe au titre
les sujets qui vont être développées ce
soir dans cette édition du 7 8 e titre
en images la crise au sein de l'opinion
à nos portes on bailleur social du
département elle et des missions
s'enchaînent à commencer par le
président du conseil d'administration et
cela pourrait bloquer certains dossiers
de travaux le préfet a été sollicité
pour dénouer la situation
une visite remarquée donc ce mardi soir
à l'ugc de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
celle d'omar sy le comédien originaire
de trappes et de laurent lafitte venus
présenter leur dernier film de l'autre
côté du périph
je vous disais interview à suivre ce
soir une opération de sensibilisation
bucco dentaire dans cette école de
classe de cp de trappes mt dans c'est
son nom est porté par la classe la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie un
constat en règle générale 80 % des
enfants de 6 ans ne consultent pas de
dentiste et puis pour les fêtes de fin
d'année du cirque acrobatique musical
plusieurs représentations sont
programmées pendant ce mois de janvier
cela se déroule à poissy à la crise donc
au sein de l'opinion après la démission
en novembre de son président le plus
gros bailleur d'île de france est
toujours sans tête les affaires
courantes sont gérés par la direction
générale mais c'est le préfet des
yvelines qui décidera de l'avenir de
l'office hlm les explications d'anthony
rêche et de patrick jacques de dixmude
l'opievoy l'office hlm n'a plus de 10
l'action le 22 novembre dernier michel
vialay et mise en minorité sur le vote
de la nomination d'un nouveau directeur
général
résultat le président de l'ot pivois
démissionne accompagné des représentants
des conseils généraux des yvelines et du
val d'oise
cette démission collective bloc alors le
vote du budget annuel et paralyse le
fonctionnement de l'office
ça a bloqué la réhabilitation de la
grande borne ça a bloqué la
réhabilitation du valais ou un plaisir
ça a bloqué des projets d'innovation
sociale avec des associations
donc ça bloquait toute la machine au
pouvoir et derrière ça ça aussi
énormément inquiéter 1000 salariés
michel vialay justifie son départ par le
flou de la trésorerie
selon lui plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros de fonds propres et disparus
mayence ans le maire de mont-joli entend
dénoncer l'absence de transparence dans
la gestion budgétaire du deuxième
offices publics de l'habitat français
qu'il s'agisse de la gestion financière
qu'il s'agisse de la gestion budgétaire
de la stratégie patrimoniale de tout ce
qui engage le fils dans la durée un
grand nombre d'informations ne sont pas
ni satisfaisante ni complète
qu'il s'agisse de l'endettement qui lui
a crû dans des proportions extrêmement
rapide en l'espace de tout juste 3 ans
de leur côté les administrateurs déplore
un manque de dialogue criant avec leur
président démissionnaire ils ont saisi
le préfet des yvelines
ce dernier a conseillé la tenue d'une
nouvelle réunion d'ici une semaine
l'opievoy gère 50 mille logements en
ile-de-france non plus de 18000 dans le
département
et en plateau je reçois ce soir le comte
paul de la panouse et la comtesse
annabelle de lapanouse bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous venez de recevoir le
prix du french heritage society un prix
et pour récompenser le travail
historique et paysager effectués sur le
château et le parc de thoiry
félicitations donc déjà pour ce prix qui
vous a été décerné vous le vivez comme
une grande fierté ou c'est un
aboutissement ou une récompense aussi
peut-être pour ensuite avoir encore
envie d'entretenir ce pas je vis surtout
ça comme une récompense pour 35 ans de
délégation n'a sauvé les scrute les gens
la victoire y est à l'écran tu me
l'avais avis que j'ai planté du fruit et
aussi mais il faut le puits était aussi
pour pouvoir instaurer un service bien
enveloppants ses pages une distinction
honorifique
non non non à 25000 de grasset qui fait
l'arrivée à 20,29 dollars ce qui fait
dans la canne milios et s'est donné à
dans le but de pouvoir restaurer les
vases et les statuts qui était vendu 20
d'alizé autres objets de pierre ont un
mental dans le jardin dont qui aura
véritablement ensuite un travail qui va
continuer qui va se poursuivre vous nous
l'avez dit ça fait 25 ans 30 ans que
vous travaillez 25 20 35 ans vous
travaillez sur ce par quels sont les
aménagements que vous y avez réalisé
justement à devoir c'était les
restaurations de la jarne anglais à qui
avait idée venue
un espèce de méchantes si vous voir à
travers la ligue à signer on ne commence
pas tout un tout enlever tout ce qui est
ainsi que marc châtaigner les espèces
très agressive faut trouver le jardin
d'eau agit ensuite j'ai à crier gare
d'olten parce que je viens de l'amérique
où on est très bel automne autrement
cela mais ça m'a manqué un peu et puis
j'ai cru aussi à des deux les autres
jardins la roseraie à la vie rurale
je fais cuire la virade et en général à
m'occuper de faire des collections de
plantes rares intéressante en en minitel
qui est en cause poussée est maintenant
plus gros challenge c'est qu'on a dû
coûter les allées dutil qui tu fais pas
des go à le navire le nôtre donc c'était
très rare exemple de prospective
inversée unique en france et on est tous
les coupés ils évitent 60 ans il est en
train de tomber et on a manqué de tout
cet été et on le dit baye et quand il
faut y aller il faut y avait hélas ils
sont coupés en train de broyer tous des
racines et on a trois ans pour les
replanter pour replanter 1 400 tati nul
pour restaurer la
on parle souvent du parc zoologique de
thoiry mais il ya tout un jardin toute
cette richesse vous avez essayé il n'y a
pas de vie animale sans vie végétale
alors ce qui est assez étonnant ça c'est
clair on a coupé les ailes etc tilleuls
par nécessité mais on a retrouvé on a
trouvé du coup le jardin anglais qui
voulait faire bars et cafés le bois de
boulogne
au 19ème siècle qui fait dans des villes
civ on a un très beau jardin anglais
qu'aidant bout de la perspective à la
française ce qui fait que ça ne
pénalisera absolument pas bien longtemps
la visite de thoiry le fait qu'ils aient
été coupés ça a été une très agréable
surprise
puis mon épouse c'est 35 mille arbres
plantés en 35 ans gharb et arbustes moi
je me suis contenté de faire venir une
variété de très belles plantes homo
sapiens des états unis qui est la belle
jardinière mon épouse et c'est elle qui
a transformé ce domaine et ce qui est
formidable avec sa dot qui sont ces 35
mille arbres et arbustes et l'a planté
c'est que quelle que soit 4 40 qui
continuent à pousser ça au moins ça ne
connaît pas la crise
voilà c'est au moins au moins
l'assurance est un bon investissement
vous l'avez encourager justement
réaliser tous ces aménagements tous ces
travaux c'était important pour maintenir
le site et l'entretenir le château on
peut le rappeler en date du 16e siècle
votre famille qui l'habite depuis seize
il ya aussi cette mission d'entretien
que vous vous êtes fixés et
d'embellissement aussi dans le problème
n'était pas de la pousser à faire vrai
problème était de réfréner des leurs et
freiner les projets fantastique et
quelquefois des n'ont pas toujours les
moyens de suivre mais ç'a toujours été
important prononcer et il n'y a pas de
vie animale sans vie végétale c'est
évident il ya plus de vie sous terre
qu'il y en a dans l'air
il ya une symbiose vie animale et
végétale et à thouars îles et les arbres
sont des acteurs sont vraiment nos
frères les arbres solide ya pas de
différence
il ya même molécule c'est la sève d'un
arbre et le sang d'un homme c'est la
même molécule est en définitive on a 50
on dit qu'on a de 1 % de différence de
gènes avec les bonobos les chimpanzés
mais nous avons 50% des jeunes d'une
banane effectivement on est vif
on va revenir sur des choses peut-être
terre à terre malgré tout c'est un coup
vous l'avez mentionné
quelquefois il faut investir pour
réaliser tout ça ça représente combien
d'investissement aussi financier vous
avez un budget pour ça chaque année vous
fixé un budget dans le fonctionnaire un
budget il ya des hommes et des
jardiniers une équipe avec sébastien de
bell qui était un jeune chef jardinier
parce que maintenant à thoiry c'est les
équipes de nos enfants qui dirige tous
donc aussi qui a avec les quinze 15 ans
qui depuis le début on va conseiller à
la belle en bonne américaine s'est dit
pour diriger le jardinier faut que je
sois compétents dont on attribue des
cours à l'école du paysage de versailles
cela
et puis alors et m'entraîne à toutes les
vacances c'est pas les animaux c'est le
safari jardin vous êtes un spécialiste
aussi du coup forcément j'arrive à avoir
une certaine connaissance d'un grand
amour des arbres mais il tenait grâce à
mon épouse bon je retiens pas les noms
latins des plantes les animaux ça me
suffit puis le marché ne veut pas vivre
mais mon épouse a donc là qu' une
compétence que je n'ai pas mais nous
avons un amour partagé pour les plantes
et et chaque vacances et un safari job
est donc finalement ce prix dédié vous a
été décerné pour tout cet investissement
depuis 35 ans sur ce sur ce parc de ce
château de thoiry on va juste faire une
pause on va donner la parole à quelques
yvelinois nous sommes allés leur poser
la question suivante est ce que vous
aimeriez être propriétaire d'un château
la vie de château ça fait presque rêver
et pourtant il ya des contraintes il
faut s'en occuper il faut financer aussi
derrière voyons les réponses des
yvelinois que nous avons rencontrés
aujourd'hui propriétaire du château bas
je pense que c'est beaucoup de travail
parce que généralement pour l'entretenir
est bon on n'a pas toujours les moyens
pour faire venir les artisans donc ceci
dit ça d'écouté agréable l'espace le
voile à se sentir dans un lieu
historique aussi non moi je transforme
en chambres d'hôtes
voilà mais je m'intéresse pas oui
j'aimerais bien m'occuper de rénover un
vieux château éventuellement mais je ne
me vois pas être dans un château sans
rien y faire rien qu'en surface de
toiture quand il faut refaire la toiture
ça doit être terrible en chauffage
tuellement ça doit être terrible aussi
pour confirmer le chauffage la toiture à
refaire soir château ça coûte cher
à moins qu'un jijel dans les couloirs
alors en maintient la chaleur dans la
chambre à coucher la bibliothèque la
salle à manger et la cuisine l'eau
liquide michenaud enfants chacun
l'appartement nous aussi
il ya les jeux que je rêve de mascate ce
serait effectivement plus simple nous
respectons les ménages
effectivement c'est forcément mais c'est
quand même fantastique on est au coeur
d'un vaisseau à voyager dans le temps
les grands pères qui nous sourit dans
les portraits on se sont assis sur les
mêmes choses que nous on utilise leur
vaisselle andorre dans leur lycée là où
sont dès qu'ils ont fait l'amour qui
sont morts et c'est quand même
extraordinaire d'être dans un vaisseau à
voyager dans le temps et quand on sort
on est dans un théâtre de la nature n'a
aucun regret de l'avoir ouvert au public
finalement ce château
en 1968 la limo la réserve social 68 67
aucun les visiteurs ont la gentillesse
de nous remercier de ce que nous avons
fait à thoiry les les accueillir alors
j'ai dit c'est à nous de vous remercier
parce que vous nous donner l'argent pour
l'entretenir et nous n'avons que le prix
du billet aucune subvention n'a que le
prix du billet pour tenir tout payer et
puis surtout ce que vous donnez à nous
et puis aux équipes qui travaillent avec
nous puis le matin sont des jeunes
équipe 1 échéance en plastique qui n'a
pas pris un sens à notre vie et ça c'est
extraordinaire et je dis quelquefois
quand un tel qu un râle parce qu'un
visiteur a été avec pourquoi il fallait
il dit attention le client est roi et
moi je ne suis que comptent les
hiérarchies après tout finalement vous
partagez cet avis aussi cette ouverture
du château
oui la vie de château telle que vous la
vivez aujourd'hui oui absolument je ne
pouvais pas concevoir autrement
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas ce que je fais
là dans un camp cette grande mission 500
les occupations qui dont le visitait la
restauration
demandez des jardins et beaucoup de
projets encore deux jours j'ai les
cartes telles choses en tête les cartons
glen merci beaucoup d'être venu donc
témoigner nous parler suite à la remise
de ce prix
remise par l'association la demeure
historique le french héritage society
pour saluer le travail mené sur la
partie historique et paysagère du parc
de thoiry merci donc à tous les deux
l'acompte le comte et la comtesse de
lapanouse été sur ce plateau dans un
instant nous allons entendre omar cissé
dans un autre registre l'enfant de
trappes est revenu à saint quentin en
yvelines pour présenter son nouveau film
de l'autre côté du périph